let's talk about the economy and
specifically the stock market a little
bit the stock market decline is
continuing stocks yesterday closed at
their lowest level in 14 months dating
back to October 2017 is roughly 14
months and unless something incredible
happens in the last two weeks of the
year stocks are going to have their
worst year in 2018 in a decade which
happens to include eight years of Barack
Obama's presidency and two years of
Donald Trump's we talked last week about
how Donald Trump according to one report
is starting to panic about whether his
trade policy and his presidency
effectively his actions as president are
starting to make the market erratic and
contributing to the stock market decline
and yesterday I jokingly satirically
tweeted blaming Barack Obama for this
and it triggered way more of a reaction
than I anticipated I tweeted again
jokingly quote I can't believe Obama
planted time bombs in the economy so
that the stock market would start
crashing now and give us the worst year
in a decade
just to make Donald Trump look bad now
most people understood that that was a
satirical tweet but shockingly many
didn't some people wrote to me angrily
simply denying the reality saying David
stocks are doing great under Donald
Trump they're not down for the year
under Trump they're up for the year I
don't even know how to respond to that I
mean if you can't just go to Google
Finance or Yahoo Finance and look at the
numbers or if you do when you don't
believe them I don't know what I can
tell you right I don't know sort of like
with with climate science if you're just
going to say the evidence is not the
evidence good luck I'm not going to be
able to really have a conversation with
you
other people warned me that it's risky
for me to tweet that satirical statement
because many of trumps followers will
see it and they'll believe it and
they'll start actually repeating this
absurdly ridiculous idea it is
interesting that Trump is now taking
another approach on Twitter which is
obviously never to mention that
stock market is falling more and more he
never talks about that but if the stock
market is up you can be sure Pat that
he's going to be tweeting about it but
instead to tweet about how bad things
are elsewhere here's a very strange
tweet from Donald Trump as all of this
chaos is going down
Trump tweets it is incredible that with
a very strong dollar and virtually no
inflation the outside world is blowing
up around us Paris is burning and China
way down the Fed is even considering yet
another interest rate hike take the
victory what victory is Trump talking
about here Pat I don't even know what
he's saying but he seems to be pointing
out I guess that things are even worse
in other countries I think it's a
classic example of Trump moving the goal
posts and it really this has to come
down to him at the end of the day if
he's gonna take all the credit for
strong metrics in the economy he has to
take the blame for the poorer metrics in
the economy and things are starting to
go downhill a little bit when he talked
about the stock market when he talked
about rates of homelessness and to some
degree we were just kind of due for this
right because we're experiencing the
second longest period of American
prosperity in history could have
happened under Hillary Clinton too
but Trump should have prepared a little
bit more with his words early on when
the economy was doing better well as
we've said before when you hang your hat
on particular metrics when those metrics
no longer are favorable to you you
either are self-defeating if you
continue to hang your hat on them or if
you never mention them again you start
to be very apparently hypocritical which
of course Donald Trump is and what he's
doing here is just trying to redirect
and of course much of what we're talking
about with stocks only has a tangential
effect on many participants in the
economy the stock market is down down
down okay a lot of people don't own
stock or don't own much stock but
they're still affected by stock market
declines in many ways which we've
discussed before but there are macro
issues which simply aren't being touched
here they're not being
touched when we talk about the stock
market they're certainly not being
touched by Donald Trump income
inequality exploded wage stagnation
continues manufacturing used as a
political football manufacturing jobs
rather than working with the reality
that a ton of those jobs aren't
returning because they simply don't
exist anymore healthcare causing people
to declare bankruptcy you could get sick
at any time and lose all of your money
and meanwhile Donald Trump is gutting
Obamacare making that problem even worth
so it's wrong to say that the stock
market only affects rich people even
though rich people disproportionately
own the stocks but it's also wrong to
say that the stock market is the only
thing that matters what's next
depends on who's making decisions Ron
Paul says that we could have a 50%
downturn in stocks which could cause a
1929 style depression that's one extreme
do we trust Ron Paul I'm not sure judge
for yourself the market dogmatists who
put all full faith in the market say the
market will solve the problem of the
market decline the market will also
solve the problems caused by the markets
decline we know that doesn't work I mean
that that's already been proven not to
be true if the noose of criminality as I
like to say continues to tighten around
Donald Trump how will that political
instability impact the stock market
probably pretty significantly the one
statement I agree with the right on on
this entire issue is we need to fix the
underlying problems to stabilize the
market and the economy the problem is we
don't agree on what those issues are
it's not quote debt it's not immigration
it's not China to the degree that some
on the right claim that it's China it's
that we have an economy that's built on
infinite growth and that doesn't work
for most people and the side effect of
it is that it's destroying our planet by
being indifferent to climate change and
the damage we're doing to the
environment if we can't even get on the
same page as to what the problem is
there's almost no chance
so ever that we're gonna be able to fix
it send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on twitter at
david pakman show